is a really troubling video that just
came out it's it's troubling because it
sheds light on evil things that go on in
our world that we want to deny but I
kind of like the video in that it sheds
light on evil things that go on in our
world that that a lot of people want to
deny this is of a witch
describing how she performs Satanic
rituals through her abortions how to
practice abortion as a magical ritual
part one my quity ifications for
teaching this I am a witch who has had
abortions and has used them as rituals
I've been through this twice and it's
birthing magic and death magic
simultaneously if you are a womb body
who has made the decision to have an
abortion keep in mind that there is
death and there is life there has been a
conception there is life that has been
conceived for me I look at the abortions
I've had as workings so just like you
would go through a spell and do things
in a very specific order you would you
would lay things out in a very specific
order because how we do our rituals and
our workings and our spell castings the
order that we do them in is the order
they play out in in the physical when
the magic like really kicks in and our
spirits that we've called on say it's
time for that working to work so if we
look at an abortion and conception
ritualistically there's a life that has
been
conceived so this we is willing to admit
something that most mainstream liberals
will not admit most pro-abortion regular
old liberals will not admit namely that
abortion obviously ends a life it
wouldn't be abortion
otherwise and she says further that the
abortion is not merely a physical action
because we're not merely physical beings
it's a spiritual action and this witch
who does witch stuff who worships and
communes with demons at least in her own
mind she thinks she's doing that she
says obviously the power of life and
death is used in a
ritual and people are going to listen to
this and they're to say man these these
young people they're really into some
weird stuff this new age weird hippie
dippy this is crazy but it's not new
this isn't new at all this has been
going on for all of human
history the thing that is new is denying
that this exists for all of human
history everywhere on Earth women like
that have called themselves witches and
killed their babies and believed that
they were communing with demons and
believed that blood sacrifices had a
spiritual consequence to them
particularly viav the worshiping and
communing with demons and now we in
modern secular liberal Society we say oh
that's all totally crazy
and yet the people who are the most
liberal in our liberal Society the
people who are the most modern liberated
feminist all the isms that we exalt in
our modern liberal
Society they agree with the old view
they agree that there are such things as
witches there are such things as demons
that the physical world has a connection
to the metaphysical World there is such
a thing as sacrifice including blood
sacrifice including human sacrifice for
goodness sakes this rapper Young Thug
who I guess is is on trial for murder
his accomplice when his accomplice was
arrested his accomplice was arrested
performing a Satanic ritual with a goat
sacrificing a goat and there's now a big
legal fight over whether or not that
evidence can be admitted to the court
because the defense is arguing that that
would Prejudice the jury yeah I think
Satanic rituals might Prejudice the jury
this woman though is is shedding light
on something that we all seem to have
forgotten so and so my question I
remember one time I was in interviewing
a Fox News host on on radio when he was
promoting a book and the book was about
Witch Trials you know he said we there's
a political Witch Hunt going on today
and his pitch for the book was well the
first thing about witch hunts that we
need to remember is there's no such
things as
witches I said no of course there are
witches at least I said that in my head
I let him get his book pitch out but
that's what I said to myself I said no
of course there which is more likely
which is more
likely that
everyone for all of human history until
about I don't know 50 or 100 years ago
in specifically in the west that
everyone for all of human history people
who believed in witches and devils and
demons and more importantly who believed
in God and angels and Grace everyone for
all of human history everywhere on Earth
other than us recently they were totally
wrong and we just happen to be
right or vice versa who do you think is
is more diluted this witchy lady talking
about how she sacrificed her children to
the devil or the purple-haired feminist
atheist Marching In the Street saying my
body my choice a pregnancy is not alive
I'm not this is just a health care
procedure and a b human is just a clump
of cells who do you think it's more
likely to be correct right now go to jus
/ns letter y letter T our friends at
genus cell have launched a new product
called genus cell 3 which works fast on
your under eye bags and puffiness genus
cell 3 is smoother more luxurious and it
uses advanced technology to deliver
complex vitamins and minerals directly
to your face for instant hydration it is
like Gatorade for your skin this new
genus cell technology keeps your skin
looking young and healthy for years to
come the genus cell fall Classics
package also includes a jawline
treatment for a more firm neck and
jawline it also includes genus cell's
anti- wrinkle moisturizer and deep
Firming Serum get your skin ready for
the cold and dry weather if you don't
look and feel your absolute best you
will get your money back no questions
asked go to genucell.com YT or you can
call 800 skin skin 211 for extra
discounts on this amazing fall package
results in 12 hours or less the immedia
effects are included for free by the way
the founder of this company great Coptic
Christian from Egypt who left there for
the American dream so head on over to
Jus cell.com slns letter y letter T or
call 800 skin SK i n 211 my Senator here
in the state of Tennessee the great
marshia
Blackburn has just announced something
that I think a lot of not just
conservatives normal people have been
waiting for for years and that is she's
going to try to get the Epstein Client
List since we're in the business of
issuing subpoenas now here are a few
more that I filed a subpoena to Jeffrey
Epstein's estate to provide the flight
logs for his private plane given the
numerous allegations of human
trafficking and a sexual abuse
surrounding Mr Epstein I think it is
very important that we identify
everybody that was on that plane and how
many trips they took on that plane and
the destinations to which they
arrived of course that's great love that
Marsh is doing this one of the great
senators in Washington
DC why has this taken so long can you
believe this I remember the Jeffrey
Epstein
story from
2015 2014 maybe I've been hearing about
Jeffrey
Epstein he was still a free man at that
point then finally they arrest him then
what H oh then whoopsy Daisy the jail
camera went out and a mustachioed
Hillary Clinton showed up and rang his
Little Neck speaking of ringing one's
Little Neck and then we just never heard
anything the Department of Justice has
spent the last couple of years trying to
spy on Catholic
churches uh arresting pro-life parents
of six and seven for peacefully
demonstrating outside of abortion
clinics and exposing the horrors of
abortion have uh called parents akin to
domestic terrorists for wanting to have
some say over their kids' curriculum not
have their kids be taught weird groomer
porno stuff in in Elementary School
classrooms doj's been really focused on
that where's the Epstein Client List how
is it that gilain Maxwell Epstein's uh
intelligence connected business
partner went on trial was obviously
arrested and yet we still do we have one
name
confirmed we know some of the people who
were on the plane but do we confirm do
we have
it no I frankly I I want The epsteam
Client List move to the top of the list
to me that's more important than Hunter
Biden it's more important than
impeaching Joe Biden I want to know who
in our public life is so compromised man
what a great clip that was now hey hey
hey ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nolles YouTube channel we'll see
you next time